owner of a Japanese restaurant was at
work when the quake hit she said she has
never experienced such a strong tremor
their ground wobbled I had no idea what
was going on at first because the quake
hit so suddenly I closed their cupboard
doors because glasses and dishes were
crashing down on the floor the strong
jolt has knocked out electricity in the
region utility company officials say
thousands of households in Yamagata and
Niigata are without power as a result of
the earthquake which registered maximum
is 6 so 1 plus connection there were
more than 20 one-one-nine emergency
calls and we have information that
people have been injured and there are
no reports of fires and for tsunamis
accompanying this earthquake an alert
for an advisory for its Nami
has been issued between Yamagata any
scour and we got that our students and
cicuta 12:00 midnight on Wednesday here
in Japan a magnitude 6.8 quake struck
the northern part of the country meeting
with the municipalities to check the
damage situation and we are putting
priority on the rescue mission there may
be further damages and we have to stay
vigilant and to be able give information
to Japanese people on the timely and
appropriate manner and we would like to
stay vigilant and I myself Andy will be
staying in the prime minister's office
gate of neethu station you see the train
according to JR East Japan Shinkansen
bullet line had been suspended between
Tokyo and Niigata station as a result of
the earthquake but at 47 minutes past
midnight